so first of all has to be data oriented
in that sense has to be something that
is a spreadsheet it's a database to
something like that
and obviously has to come from an
appropriate source so once you have that
then we're looking at looking at that
data and we're trying to think okay
obviously no one wants to read a
200-page report nobody wants to be
handed a giant spreadsheet and be like
here look at this and try and figure out
what's going on right like that's just
not the way that people operate right so
people people are looking for something
that catches their eye because the first
thing you have to do is you have to win
their attention right so we have to
figure out what is the thing that's
gonna catch their eye and once you have
their attention what do you what do you
hit them with right so we're looking for
facts we're looking for data that stands
out in that way and once we have the the
item that we think can do that
then we we build a framework around that
we build a media and all around that so
it's all about winning people's
attention holding their attention once
you have their attention you have to hit
them with something that delivers
insight and and gets them to keep
reading and keep looking and so we're
really just building a process around
that so we're looking at that to try and
create that or stimulate that curiosity
in people so that you have this fact or
you have this initial visualization that
captures people's attention and gets
them to want to learn more and gets them
rather than being stuck in your bubble
and and just you know consuming what is
coming your way you actually want to
actively seek out more information so
that you can learn more on the subject
for me and from our company's
perspective or our view is basically
like we're trying to take things that
are complex and make them simple
generally speaking it's about stuff
that's future-looking
and it's stuff that relates to if you're
an investor it's your portfolio or if
you're in business
it's your company's future if you're an
entrepreneur it's how you need to build
your business for the future or you know
that kind of stuff right so it's like
what what can we help people with in
term
of the decisions they make now with
respect to their future so the speed of
technological change is important the
speed of economic change is important so
like is GDP per capita increasing or
decreasing and why is trade increasing
or decreasing so looking at those
factors business segments generally
right so is this particular industry
taking off something like cannabis right
is this industry taking off or is it you
know going to hit a low and so people
are trying to figure out what
opportunities there are in the future
based on these you know emerging
industries or emerging countries or what
have you and you have to know if they're
for real or not so yeah it's the rate of
change but it's across a wide spectrum
of different categories because that's
something that's measurable and it's
also something that we can visualize
right so from that perspective that and
that's kind of like yeah that's the
number one thing that we'd be looking at
someone's opinion me contradict yours
where is my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake on we are still
on site in the beautiful Vancouver
British Columbia in Canada we are now
going to be talking about data
visualization and so much more we have
Jeff there's our day joining us on the
show hi Jeff
hey thanks Mattamy thanks for coming on
the program I'm so pumped for our
conversation
Jeff is founder and editor-in-chief at
visual capitalists which is a digital
media company that exclusively publishes
rich visual content on investing in
business with annual user growth
doubling each year visual capitalist
reaches over 2 million people per month
with clients such as McKinsey Blackrock
the UN and the World Bank I love what
you guys do I love the way you make
these rich data visualizations it is so
important to take the complexity of this
world that we find ourselves and try and
make it relatable for people and to try
and inspire them towards their own
self-actualization towards our
eradication of ignorance and you guys do
that and you do it across a myriad of
fields which is another thing that I
find super inspirational as our show is
very Polymathic like that as well
Jeff this has been going on nine years
now
you guys have covered such a wide array
of topics you guys have 21 people and
staff designers researchers I mean
it's so cool seeing what you guys have
produced so I want to start things off
by asking you about how you guys even
find what to figure out to show in the
complexity of the world there's so many
things there's so much information
actually being able to struck
sure that and disseminate it teach us
about that style of process and also how
it changed from nine years ago until now
yeah Wow so I think that that process
started as something that was really
more of a gut instinct than anything
else so when we started how we got to
where we are today it was kind of
finding things that we thought were
particularly interesting or that really
helped people get that little bit of
insight that could be either you know
water cooler talk at the office or it's
the thing that inspires them to do the
next big thing right and getting people
to have that little tidbit of
information that they can now talk about
whether it's you know that fact or that
insight or whatever it is
you know we want to deliver that on a
daily basis to people and so that's it's
changed over time which is weird
it was very intuitive to begin with and
we were just kind of looking at what was
catching our eye what was something they
were like when you heard that fact
you're like wow that's something that
really inspired me or got me to think
and over time we've been working to
codify how we come up with that and
because now we have a bigger team and so
we have other people that have to be
coming up with the stuff on a daily
basis as well it can't be me or someone
like Nick roughtly who's our managing
editor we can't be coming up with it all
the time we have to be has to be
something that's systemic throughout the
organization where we're all looking for
that kind of information so how is that
changed over time and and what is it
like today and that's an interesting
question and I think that probably the
best way to do it would be to think
about it in terms of of data which is
how we always think about things right
so things that are very qualitative or
things that are opinions or things that
are not looking at it from a
quantifiable independent perspective for
those items they just don't really work
with our process so first of all has to
be data oriented in that sense ask me
something that is a spreadsheet is a
database is something like that and
obviously has to come from an
appropriate source so once you have that
then we're looking at looking at that
data and we're trying to think okay
obviously no one wants to read a
200-page
report nobody wants to be handed a giant
spreadsheet and be like here look at
this and trying to figure out what's
going on right like that's just not the
way that people operate right so people
people are looking for something that
catches their eye because the first
thing you have to do is you have to win
their attention right so we have to
figure out what is the thing that's
going to catch their eye and once you
have their attention what do you what do
you hit them with right so we're looking
for facts we're looking for data that
stands out in that way and once we have
the the item that we think can do that
then we we build a framework around that
we build an a media angle around that so
it's all about winning people's
attention holding their attention once
you have their attention you have to hit
them with something that delivers
insight and and gets them to keep
reading and keep looking and so we're
really just building a process around
that I love how you put it from the
perspective of this in when you give
them some sort of data visualization
it's about catalyzing some sort of
inspiration or further awakening or
realization that then makes it fun for
them to go and share it with other
people to say that hey I now know this
it's become part of my knowledge base
and now I share with other people and
they go wow I didn't know that and it
makes for a more aware world a more
factual world a world where ignorant can
decrease at a more rapid rate and
collective objective knowledge can
increase at a more rapid pace which is
extremely needed and then I also like
how you put it how through the evolution
of visual capitalist there's there's
been a process where you guys have to
figure out it's been you know you're you
are a part of the attention economy as
are we and and it's it's not only you
know people see that you're here to
catalyze that inspiration and that
awakening so they want to work with you
they want to watch what you're doing but
furthermore is you do have to figure out
how to make it so that
this this hundred page report on a
specific topic you do what we do in many
ways which is you have to parse it for
the most profound most awakening stats
and then you have to visualize you have
to visually represent it for people in a
way where they go wow that was good and
there's so many different ways to
visually represent it and I would love
for you to actually explain those ways
as as many people just see like pie
charts as like such a common
mathematical representation bar graphs
there's many of these different ways to
represent data and infographics have
become really popular where it's you
know multiple percentages with
visualizations along the way and so
let's have you explain the process of
when you do encounter something that's
super profound and awakening you want to
then parse it you want to then represent
that data and how do you pick what
medium to represent it as yeah that's a
great question and it the answer really
varies depending on what type of
information it is and and what the
subject matter is and how you want to
get that message out to people so for us
lately we're trending towards doing
things that are more I mean in the
social media world where you're just
looking at something on Instagram or
something at wheat or whatever like you
really need to capture people's
attention with that thing you can't
expect something that's kind of you know
just a part of something bigger to be
what drives people in to read more and
employs them to to examine a topic
deeper so what we're looking for is is
first of all what is that one tidbit
that we can pull that's going to capture
people's attention to do that I think
that it's really an examination
of what what fact is going to be
something that triggers something in
someone's mind the triggers in sight or
gets them thinking or it's something
that they've never heard before and to
figure that out you have to really have
a good sense of the media environment
you have to have a sense of who your
audiences and as I said at first that
was a gauge that was fairly intuitive
that you know I was operating on which
was like okay I think that our audience
is gonna be really surprised to learn
that for example the median age on all
continents when you look at that the
median age of Africa is 18 years old
that's a crazy fact right and you know
when you look at something like that for
me it just jumps off the page and I'm
like if we show this in in an
appropriate way for example the way that
we did show that is we used you know
colors to represent the scale of median
age across all the different continents
and of course Africa stands out by its
cup color and compared to about 35 or so
as the righty in Asia and Europe is even
older it's in the 40s and so you have
this color spectrum where everything is
yeah 30s and 40s and then you have one
that clearly stands out and so we're
thinking about it not only in terms of
that the the fact that is important but
also like when we visualize it how are
we going to pull that out and what
devices can we use which as you alluded
to you know we have a variety of
different you know visual things that we
can leverage so like are we putting this
in a specific type of chart or are we
using a map or are we using a particular
color sheet color scheme that's going to
help us show this thing what are the
different elements of storytelling that
we can employ to tell this right so are
we is it going to be a narrative or is
it going to be something that has you
know characters or archetypes or like
how are we gonna actually show this from
a storytelling perspective as well so
we're trying to put all these different
pieces to the bug of the puzzle together
and at the end the day if we do it right
and if we do it the best possible way
it's going to be in the case of
the map on median age it's gonna be
something that stands out and you're
like holy crap I now see that you know I
not only have you learned this fact
about Africa but it actually really
tickles your imagination and now you're
like okay well what does that mean for
the world what does that mean for the
future of society and what does that
mean for the for our perspective what
does that mean for the future of
business so we're looking at that to try
and create that or stimulate that
curiosity in people so that you have
this fact or you have this initial
visualization that captures people's
attention and gets them to want to learn
more and gets them rather than being
stuck in your bubble and and just you
know consuming what is coming your way
you actually want to actively seek out
more information so that you can learn
more on the subject I really appreciate
how you take something that can be
written as a fact of Africa median age
18 and just have that be just a message
that goes out which maybe has a a chance
of sticking in people's essence at maybe
one or two and 10 let's say whatever
just as a as of let's play with these
numbers but then when you add the actual
visualization component of showing that
they are the color let's say light green
on the on the map and then you have
these colors of like like darker red in
Europe and US and the Americas Asia etc
and then you and then people see that
Wow and then you have that spectrum that
shows them that great that gradient that
coloration it it lands it of maybe in
three out of ten or four out of ten
people just with the visual in addition
to it so you're already you know with
the text with the text exactly the
visual plus the text can land it in more
people's essences it will make it better
for them to retain it share it with
people down the line
so that component being crucial and then
also there is a there's a a storytelling
component too in which is it's maybe not
only about selling it logically but
selling it emotionally and so it's kind
of like can you pair together the brain
with the heart and I really like this
way of elia cuz it can be in a sense
something on lines of you know Africa's
median age being 18 and then comma how
do we how can we how are they going to
catalyze the future something like that
rich yeah which one kind of gets people
excited about well interesting well then
well how are they going to catalyze the
future then how is that big imagination
explosion going to affect the rest of
our world and then that kind of hits the
heart side right hitting both sides is
really important right because it's all
about how people learn and absorb
information and the truth is that we do
it in so many different ways and people
are all very different right so we know
and it's our business that you know
sixty-five percent people are visual
learners right and so that's the
majority of people and our thought
process is that the majority people are
actually not getting most of their
information in the way that's best for
them to learn which is actually really
tragic right if we want everybody to
learn and to pick up as much information
as possible it needs to be in a format
that they're gonna pick it up in and if
all we're giving them is like here's a
long report read it men we've all been
to high school right how many people in
high school are people that are going to
learn that way right a lot of people
learn by doing a lot of people learn by
visuals a lot of people will learn by
audio a podcast right so you have to
have different things in different
formats for people and so for us it's
about stimulating that visual format for
that that large chunk of the population
that needs to learn that way and you're
right you can add in other elements to
it it doesn't have to be purely data
data can be a tool and it can be a
really powerful tool and
a lot of situations it might not be the
best way to lead a story other ways or
like maybe you want to create context
around something and data isn't the
appropriate way to do it maybe it's
instead a narrative or storytelling or
maybe it's asking a question yes yes I
like that so then the combination of the
you know the stat with the combination
of the visualization with the
combination of the story the heart
component could land in five out of ten
people's yeah and it could resonate with
that many more people just by by
curating the content in a way that
catalyzes the deepest amount of
awareness shift which is ideally what we
want to see happen with the content
around the world then creating more
signal I mean we talked about this so
much on the program for just the
importance of taking these hour-long
conversations and compressing them into
knowledge graphs and having one for
every single episode these are things
that we want to do as we scale and that
by doing that you have this medium that
is okay
if you do want to watch an hour-long
conversation on a subject do it if you
want to explore the couple minute
infographic knowledge graph on what was
discussed it's there as well there's a
highlight reel of a couple minutes and
so you have all these different ways of
exploring the content in that subject
because maybe you only want to watch the
five-minute highlight reel on the
biotech episode but then you want to
watch the whole hour on the data
visualization then you only want to read
the infographic on the blockchain
conversation that happened last week so
that's another big parts of this which I
think you know you guys do add your you
know you add a good amount of story is
it on every single one of the posts that
you make you add yeah your own
researchers and visualizers have a body
of text exact ition yeah
yeah and one other interesting thing
about that as well is when you're
looking at
producing a piece of content as you know
it's not only about that big piece of
contents about chopping it up and
creating different ways to access that
content and what's really useful I think
about some of the stuff that we're able
to do is we're able to take something
that is like a 200 page report somewhere
else condense it into that 5 minute read
and then you know if someone wants to
just like okay I don't want to commit
all this time during this giant report
but I can commit five minutes to read
this quick infographic it explains this
complex subject the great thing about
that is that you're hopefully going to
stimulate you know a percentage of that
population is looking at that and
they're gonna be like you know I
actually I might want to read the larger
report because this is the subject I'm
now interested in and I'm now I now have
that I'm now an active learner and I
want to go and learn more about it yeah
you know man this is this has so much to
do with efficacy of knowledge
dissemination I love that and we have a
lot to explore as well that I'm looking
forward to talking to you guys about
after our convo I want to I want to
touch on there seems to be so much
knowledge to pick to condense and
further disseminate and given the sheer
breadth and that that has been unleashed
with the information technology age how
are you guys even picking yeah so so
where can you start on that question
right it's I mean with the reason that
we exist in the first place is is I
think that there is a lot of not only a
lot of information and topics to cover
but there's also a general clutter of
information as or misinformation or or
whatever you want to call it stuff that
is not actually super useful and so
where we start so I think that for me
and from our company's perspective our
view is basically
like we're trying to take things that
are complex and make them simple
generally speaking it's about stuff
that's future-looking
and it's stuff that relates to if you're
an investor it's your portfolio or if
you're in business
it's your company's future if you're an
entrepreneur it's how you need to build
your business for the future or you know
that kind of stuff right so it's like
what what can we help people with in
terms of the decisions they make now
with respect to their future and so the
things that we choose are things that we
think can play into that so for example
if you're an investor how the
demographics of the world are shifting
in the long term actually is a really
important thing for you right it affects
everything because that means everything
from the you know the amount of old
people versus young people it's going to
play a role in terms of the solvency of
governments right if you have too many
dependents and not enough working
population that's going to create all
kinds of problems right or if you have a
ton of young people and few old people
that's also gonna play out in your
economy as well so this is gonna have
different impacts in different places or
you know as far as demographics go
things like immigration and things like
that have an impact too so understanding
what's happening globally with that will
empower you to make better decisions as
an investor or if you're if you're
leading a company you're also going to
sort you also need to know what's going
on with that too right because what your
next move is is going to depend on like
do I move into the Indian market do I
move into the German market like you
need to have a sense of what's happening
there right and and so the future
looking aspect there is really important
so you know demographics is an example
of a topic that we weigh into a lot but
there's many others as well but the
ultimate question is like how how does
this topic is this something that's
applicable on a on a global basis to
people that they need to know for this
stuff is it something that is going to
have profound effects on doing business
or making decisions
is it something that you can do
something about because you know if it's
something that's changing and you can
actually make changes in your life or
portfolio to deal with it then it's kind
of a moot point so yeah we're looking at
those those kind of things to try and
figure out what are these forces that
we're going to that are going to
influence the future and then what is
what is the data around those forces
that is the most poignant whoa all right
so we have where you started us off with
taking what is the continuation of our
initial earlier conversations about
having this objective dissemination of
crucial knowledge that is completely
against the streams of misinformation
propaganda and I mean the internet
research agency right there's all of
these places that have deep roots in
trying to disseminate things that are in
a sense evil or bad or trying to
catalyze harm in some ways and then you
have these great sources that need to be
tried to you know propped up onto
pedestals around the world and we like
talking about yes you know visual
capitalists yes our show yes
in a nutshell there's all these other
great channels that are trying to do
their absolute best and get you
awakening content around awakening
that's you know really really solid data
that's being compressed and shared with
you but then this next point that you
bring up which is that how do you do
things like show where entrepreneurs or
or scientists or artists or other people
from around the world investors where
how can you show them what is coming up
that is exciting neck
and because it's not only about showing
these trends from where you see you know
2020 heading where you see the future
heading and the roaring 2020s that were
about to approach with all of that in
that the Internet Internet of Things
blockchain and crypto neuro tech biotech
AR VR I mean it's all over the place
quantum computing where things are
heading and so you got a you know show
them that angle so you have to be aware
of all of those different fields and how
they're changing the landscape but also
like you indicated demographics am I
going to be taking my company next or
making it in investments next into
Germany or India and and how do I know
based on the demographics in those
regions and something that's also
complex to know is that you you do have
to have some sort of an idea of the
zeitgeist of those countries because our
in India a lot of young people right now
are using a very Jen's es platform
called tick-tock and so you got to know
like well maybe it's important to teach
the companies that are trying to market
into India about how to make 15-second
videos dancing videos so yes it's this
whole process you got to know about the
zeitgeist of that country I mean there's
so many things there's of course there's
you know there's Hinduism and there's
Sikhism and there's there's all of these
you know also spiritual and religious
sorts of things that are also very
important to consider what are the main
exports of Germany versus I mean exports
or imports of these countries in India
yeah I mean there's a lot of information
to take into consideration right the I
mean we don't really see ourselves as a
group that's trying to get all of that
information in one place I think that's
more of a Wikipedia or you know googles
mission or something like that right but
what I think we can do is I think we can
we can add some pressure and you know
pull on that lever that gets people
looking in the right place right we can
we can help people find you know when
you're looking at an 8020 rule or
something like that for like of all the
things that you mentioned about India
and Germany which of those things
actually matter right for someone that's
looking at making an investment or going
into business there right there's a
certain things that 20% this can make to
80 percent of the difference right so we
can we can use our ability to parse
information and to visualize it and to
to hopefully show some of those areas
that are particularly interesting that's
like this this is what matters here and
you should try and learn more of it
before you do anything else you should
learn more about that so we can direct
people into the right places by
highlighting information that is
particularly poignant yeah I like the
focus on that Perret oh that 80/20
that's so crucial well you can't do
everything right and you and also if we
try to go too far into the weeds then
people are gonna be like well what do
you like what are you talking about
right you're talking about this random
subject in this random country and it
doesn't really have an effect on my
day-to-day life or doesn't have an
effect on my future necessarily so you
have to we have to figure out which of
these which of these items are gonna be
the most interesting and most compelling
to people and also what's going to have
the biggest effect on the future okay so
given the subject of business and
investing and demographics of a rapidly
changing information technology world
were what do you guys look for in terms
of signal in terms of the 20% that
you're going to visualize for people
yeah I think generally speaking the best
signals are going to be are going to be
business signals right so growth like
the rate of change of something so the
rate of change of population is going to
be very linked to what kinds of
opportunities are going to be there and
what kind of you know what's happening
in the business world there right a
country that's depopulating is going to
be a very different situation than a
country that is doubling in population
right or so percentage growth is one
thing obviously I think a rate of
automation sure yeah no absolutely yeah
so if you're looking at it from the
technological point of view the rate of
automation is going to be a big
component of that when you look at
places like Korea or Japan or what have
you I mean it's going to be ultimately a
very different society and situation
than it is going to be in somewhere
that's where everything is manually done
right and so those have different
implications for investors and for
businesspeople and for people and for
society at large right yeah so when
looking at business it seems like your
number one is population well like a
radar affix rate of change
yeah rate of change in general all right
it seems and Jen okay I said number one
is rate of change and then under rate of
change is kind of like demographic crest
yeah different categories different
categories so rate of change is kind of
like demographics as people are the most
in a sense valuable way of understanding
rate of change like again as population
decreasing or increasing what is the
rate of change that it is increasing or
decreasing at because these are the
people that are going to be engaged in
the world that are going to be the ones
that are trying to create more value in
that country they're gonna be bringing
their ideas into that country etc into
the world so then there's that as a
measurement of like economic success and
stuff like that but then the next thing
that could be under this rate of changes
like how quickly technology is evolving
in that crash rate yeah so so the speed
of technological change is important the
speed of economic change is important so
like is GDP per capita increasing or
decreasing and why is trade increasing
or decreasing so looking at those
factors business segments generally
right so is this
particular industry taking off something
like cannabis right is this industry
taking off or is it you know going to
hit a low and so people are trying to
figure out what opportunities there are
in the future based on these you know
emerging industries or emerging
countries or what have you and you have
to know if they're for real or not so
yeah it's the rate of change but it's
across a wide spectrum of different
categories is that's it's something
that's measurable and it's also
something that we can visualize right so
from that perspective that and that's
kind of like yeah that's the number one
thing that we'd be looking at yeah I
like the ways of visualizing where
emerging markets are heading because it
gives us both a insight into the
importance of figuring out the best ways
I think to democratize the fruits of
those emerging markets otherwise we have
the same scenarios where over 50% of all
new wealth that is created goes to the
top one percent which is this continuous
process that were all experiencing but
then we don't mimic nature in the sense
that these large trees are sequestering
carbon and nutrients and then
distributing them across roots and
fungal systems the smaller trees and
seedlings that same process is very
clearly not happening in our wealth
inequality scenario and so I really like
this idea of can we get more people to
figure out ways of micro financing the
emerging markets and then having it so
that people can just put a hundred
dollars into those emerging markets and
then get the fruits from that or have
inclusive stake holding as the social
contract that makes it so that um
environments and cities and future
generations actually get on pieces of
the pie
as well I like how you talked about you
know GDP and trade in that sense which
are economic measurements but they are
also don't necessarily take into account
the the measurement of someone's
spiritual enlightenment or their own
well-being and health so so this is also
tough because we want to try and
visualize components like that so this
is why we talked about on the program
that's something along the lines of that
that takes them the full biometric
readout of your level of spiritual
enlightenment which may be something
around eg EKG or microbiome etc and
could potentially give us an idea of how
many of these 1500 billionaires and
global ruling elite that run countries
and the big companies etc how many of
them actually have a deep sense of
interconnectedness of unconditional love
of deep presence versus egotistical
tendencies and self-dealing tendencies
and so I'd love to see data being
visualized in that regard as well
because it's great to see
yes investing yes business yes at the
same time can we also see the level of
spiritual actualization of this planet
has and the deep importance of that
moving forward to make sure there's less
suffering make sure there's more sharing
and more love and compassion yeah so one
interesting area of overlap is that I
don't think I would equate it to you
know that that spiritual element 100%
but I do think that like we do visualize
a lot of data around things like
happiness right so and I think happiness
is going to be as sort of it's as
universal of a measure of that stuff as
you can have does I think when you talk
about spirit
I think people are gonna think about
that in different ways right people have
different religious faiths or people
that are you know people on the
meditation side of things all of these
people will interpret that as a
different kind of thing right whereas I
think happiness is a pretty universal
thing where you can say okay are you
happy yes or no right and I think
whether you talk to someone from
Guatemala if you talk to someone they're
from Russia like are you happy or sad I
think even given different cultures and
language I think these are gonna be
fairly it's not gonna be perfect but
it'll be fairly Universal terms right
and so what's interesting is that we
have looked at things like what are the
happiest countries in the world what
relation is there between happiness and
wealth or or GDP per capita things like
that and you know it's not it's not
going all the way to what you're what
you're suggesting but it's a way to it's
a framework to help begin to understand
it and to understand it from a
perspective that at least has that
somewhat quantifiable aspect to it
and there's a really interesting results
actually which is that in terms of GDP
per capita right which is the amount of
economic production per person in a
country that's actually linked to
happiness up to a certain point right so
once you get people to a certain point a
certain amount of GDP per capita that
actually raises their happiness levels
significantly this is water this is
obvious right I know yeah when you think
of it it's pretty obvious right which is
like exactly having access to the most
basic things the most essential things
the very like bottom parts of the sort
of like pyramid of needs right that you
have to go through like Maslow's
hierarchy kind of thing I mean like if
you can provide those basic things
that's going to get you to sort of like
a medium level of content Ness and then
after that it's as you know it's like
self-actualization and things like that
that are going to be sort of that next
thing that you have to get to right so
that's that's where things start
splitting off right which is like once
you get to that minimum level of
happiness that that you can get to for
material stuff now this giant spectrum
of countries that are all over the place
in terms of happiness and some that that
like actually punch above their weight
and many that punch below their weight
respective to where they are on the
economic spectrum Latin America actually
is is really well known for punching
above their weight in terms of like
their happiness level is much higher
than you would predict based on GDP per
capita which is interesting because then
you have to ask yourself what kind of
cultural norms and what kind of trends
in Latin America are contributing to
that are there things we can learn from
that and apply to other cultures and/or
your own life right to be happier yeah
versus the and also the seeing the
opposite where GDP per capita can be
high the levels of happiness and
well-being are low right which makes it
feel like there's something about them
users disconnect there's a disconnect
and the the matrix environments that
we've built I think may be the ones to
to blame in that sense because you know
looking behind this this backdrop of of
that that we have on the on the program
today we have the concrete jungle of a
downtown Vancouver here and as beautiful
as it is to have these wealth creation
machines that are cities we also
understand deeply that there are
literally if you think about nature per
capita in metropolis
it's that it's it's it's it's [ __ ] it's
it's crap it's bad it's poor it's it's
very low we don't have our beautiful
interconnection and interdependence with
with water present here with trees with
animals with other plants with things
that we are deeply interconnected with
that's why a light pollution so we can't
see our beautiful stars there are so
many aspects
this that take us away from the from the
the happiness and the well-being so that
it makes it seem like yes we can take
these things from you know why what are
the philosophies the morals and the
ethics of places like Latin America
where they have a higher level of
happiness and well-being than their GDP
per capita indicates well what can we
find out from that but also what can we
find out from areas that have lower
levels of of happiness and well-being
and I think that it's probably feelings
of a lack of self-actualization lack of
feelings of separation lack of feelings
of interconnectedness being stuck in a
day-to-day grind basically yeah I think
is a big factor as well I think you know
a lot of people in cities regardless of
whether in New York or whether you're in
San Antonio I think that it's a lot of
people that live in cities are sort of
on that how do you how do you escape
that day-to-day okay you wake up go to
work do your thing come back turn on TV
go to bed wake up go to work do your
thing that's hard right how do you
escape that so I I think that's totally
a question that's worth asking which is
what is the what are the ways on both
sides of the spectrum
why is Latin America happier than it
would you would guess and why are
certain places and certainly in in
Western economies there are certain ones
where they're less happy than you would
expect yeah
what are the differences what is the
Delta and and what if you can determine
what those things are culturally yeah
then there's something that you can do
you can apply that information yes yes
this speaks again very highly to the
importance of figuring out these
variables that are influencing the
specific trends that we're talking about
in this last point and it does take a
lot of skill it takes a lot of nuance it
takes a lot of multi variability
analysis you can't
try and think in binary terms here there
is you can't have cognitive bias or
cognitive ease happening this is this is
going to take a lot of cognitive
resources and a lot of patience it feels
a lot like I relate this point a lot to
archeology in an anthropology in the
sense that we have very deep species
amnesia we we struggle with
understanding that you know just a
hundred years ago we discovered the the
code of hammurabi right we just
discovered something that's almost 4,000
years old that gives us a deep
understanding of the first primordial
ideas of constitution and what it was
like to try and codify an evolving city
of people and think about how many more
things like that are buried across the
planet and so it's gonna take a long
time for us to focus our resources on
excavating out those specific things in
order for us to gain a better nuanced
and multivariate view of what our
species was actually like in the
evolutionary process and so if you're on
the feeds every single day and you're
looking at these instant posts from
seven minutes ago someone post some news
article you know really think about how
much time they spent excavating out the
data from that because the 24/7 news
cycle and the clickbait es mentalities
of the attention economy business plans
are not focused on nuance and
multivariable 'ti in the gray area and
what's gonna take you more cognitive
resources and what's going to take them
more time to research and visualize
whereas places like visual capitalist
simulation we're trying to do our best
to take that that longer period of time
to come up with the most important gray
area and nuance and visualize it in ways
that make you have a better
understanding of the reality that we're
in those are two did that in a sense is
black and white that is very binary the
difference between those two things of
course there is some gray area but
really it's like do you are your sources
that you're looking at today deeply
nuanced complex taking their time
visualizing it in a specific way or are
they just trying to feed you something
that you click on in a 24/7 news cycle
you know I looked through your YouTube
feed and I was a little bit surprised I
didn't find any outrage in there you
know that's how you get clicks I don't
know if you knew that but I was looking
through and it was a little bit
disappointing to see you there clearly
you don't understand today it's a modern
economy but yes no I mean if you're not
if you're not geared towards that and if
you're not geared towards those clicks
then hopefully you're you're on the
other end you know I think we found a
bit of a way to and we've been lucky in
the way that we've been able to sort of
hack that side of things which is like
that the nuanced complex hard to
understand that side of the coin is the
way worse and to beyond if you're trying
to make a business of it right it's
really hard and and I think that you
have to use everything you have in your
toolkit to get that information out in a
way that actually has some element of
you know word of mouth spread to it or
you can capture someone's imagination
just analogy where you like you take
what you basically created as this
beautiful data representation or nuanced
data representation a visual catalyst
but then what you do is this
multivariate long process that
took with this you find again just like
the best way to to story tell it and
given the attention economy yes
given that what is the one graphic that
we want to add to the poster what does
the one sentence that right it's both
brain and heart yeah the post and we say
that when we when we develop stuff to
write because we are writers spend so
much time figuring out you know the
topic that they're there you go through
all the research they go through all the
topic and then you have our our design
side and they spend so much time
designing the whole thing but at the end
of the day there's this there is this
information economy element to it which
is like I always tell them that like 50%
of the like outcome of a post that we're
creating is basically going to be
determined by what is the title of the
post what is the the image that shows up
when you see it on an email blast or in
social media or whatever and what is
your description of that right and it's
sad to say but that those three things
have a huge you know determine they
determine the predictability of like
whether this thing is going to have a
million views or whether it's gonna have
10,000 views and you know in our
business we want to skew things towards
getting more eyeballs on things than
fewer right and of course we do a lot of
things because we just find them
interesting and we want to get some
eyeballs on them as well right but so
trying to how do you how do you do that
balance right
and and so the way that we frame
something is hugely important in terms
of getting eyeballs on that so that more
people can learn about that subject and
yeah it's hard and it's one of the ways
that we've been able to sort of hack
into the that it's not the outrage side
of things but it's certainly the
attention span social media side of
things which I think that yeah people
want to be outraged and people find ways
to be outraged about our things anyways
even though they're like very
data-driven which actually is one of the
most mind-boggling things that we
experienced on day to day basis because
we get emails all over the place that's
like why did you color this country this
color and like don't you know that this
color represents something it's like
okay well what
I don't know like it's just a color
scheme right so there's all kinds of
funny stuff there but no I mean we but
we try and hack it the best that we can
so that we can get some of the best of
both worlds right maybe in a way it's
viewing maybe some of the more cancerous
essences of the attention economy as one
disgusting way of doing it and then it's
viewing some of the more these are like
strategic it's tactfulness is what it is
it's it's it's it's compression its
synthesis and dissemination and rather
than a click Beatty cancerous
manipulation propaganda on this side
it's like we're trying to catalyze
enough enlightenment around the world
that eradicate suffering faster that
increases objective truth faster that
makes it so that people are able to
collectively prosper faster and so
that's the side that we're coming at and
I I like being able to distinctively
view those things because I think it's
becoming very clear very fast that
people are experiencing the death of
mainstream media and the rise of
independent media but it has to be not
only yes being catalyzed by the the it
is being catalyzed by the Giants of
distribution in many ways but to be able
to patron those independent media
organizations if you do believe in them
is very important visual capitalists
just you guys just sold out your first
book visualizing change which is epic
that you guys had a sellout for the
first book but um you and I were talking
about this before starting you have a
new book coming out
20 yep as well which were very pumped
for but we were just talking about
before we started all of that data from
visualizing change was from 2018 and
what happens in the exponential
technology Information Age is that 90%
of all new data is created in these most
recent two years and then you know so
you guys have to be looking at basically
the end of projecting quartz like the
end of 2020 as you're trying to make the
next book yeah the the best aspects of
visualizing change are the ones that are
RI they're timeless so like we did a
couple things that are historical right
so those are timeless thank God right
other things that are projecting the
future out to something like 2030 like
some of those things are pretty good too
but anything that's talking about data
this year last year last couple years it
all feels come out of date right now
when I read through it which is why we
decided not to print additional copies
of it
but yeah it's all driven by the speed of
technological change is definitely one
aspect of it I think also having data
from two years ago or even one year ago
is just not optimal if you're trying to
make decisions about something and also
the trends and the focuses that that
people care about have changed a little
bit too right the the zeitgeist I guess
you could describe it as like the
feeling of what's important and what's
not important I think there's certain
aspects of the book that I already feel
a couple years down the line are not as
important as they were at that time and
so how do you how do you when you're a
data focused company how do you and each
thing is something that can go out of
date how do you navigate that right it's
an interesting question which in the
next book that we do I think we're going
to be trying to optimize for that which
is like how do we focus on data that's
going to be relevant for the next five
years yes and and there are projections
out there done by a lot of great
organizations and companies that I think
are they could lend that data to us that
I think would be good for accomplishing
that so
look forward to the next channel and we
knew this would be a challenge with our
first book as we put together we knew oh
man this is gonna feel out of date in
five years for sure but it actually felt
it is like only a couple years before it
fell out or felt out of date so that's
mind-boggling to me now let's have you
give a couple examples of what is data
that is historically timeless that
you're able to visualize and then versus
data that is 20 16 17 18 even 19's data
we see this today where it's very almost
obsolete in a sense to be talking about
what was happening with the social media
companies and the election and all that
type of stuff it's already kind of like
ah that's what's happening now versus
what is being projected out to like
2030s where everyone's talking about
everyone's gonna have a our glasses
we're all gonna be connected to 5g all
time blah blah blah so how do you guys
yet let's talk about those three
different categories yeah it's great
yeah so one of the most interesting
things when you're looking back at this
previous book that we did and some of
the data sets that I think have not been
timeless one of them that really stands
out is we have a visualization in there
about the number of AI CEOs for
cryptocurrency that occurred over the
course of I don't know maybe was over
2017 or 2018 or whenever there was sort
of that boom happening and now not only
is like the feeling about crypto is
already different right people are
thinking about the blockchain but
they're thinking about the blockchain in
terms of like how it's going to affect
the future of business and society and
not as much about the investment side of
all these icos happening and and people
throwing money in this new a new white
paper for a new cryptocurrency and all
that kind of stuff right so that's kind
of just disappeared off the radar and
not only is the the ICO become less
relevant now because of of like token
offerings and like you know the whole
ecosystem is basically evolved so
donnelly are they're not happening but
they're not even really relevant anymore
and so then the question is is like when
you're looking back at this data from
this that particular year is that is it
even useful at all anymore it unless if
you're looking specifically at what
happened that year I don't think it's
useful in any context so you know that's
an example of something that did not
stand the test of time and so it's like
okay no more stuff like that right let's
cut that in the next book but when you
look at something like okay so maybe
world debt showing that in terms of
dollar terms and showing that in terms
of percentage debt as a percent of GDP
and and that kind of thing
world that changes sort of fast but not
that fast
whether it's so we did one a couple
years ago and it was at so government
debt was at sixty trillion we did it
this year and it was at up to 69
trillion so yeah there's a difference
there over the two or three years but
it's not a game-changing difference and
when you look at debt to GDP of
different countries there's a couple of
countries that change but for the most
part you know the u.s. is hanging at 104
percent debt to GDP you know other
Western nations are around the amount
that they were at before Japan is still
the biggest in terms of debt to GDP so
you when you look at all these things
they haven't really changed that much
over that period of time so something
like that I'd be a lot more confident
you know make sure that we're getting
the very latest data before publishing
and that when if you look at that three
years from now four years from now it's
still going to be approximately the same
unless some cataclysmic world event
happens where it changes that right so
in instances like that you can be a
little bit more sure that it's going to
be the same so and then here's the thing
is if you're talking about something
that's fast moving like crypto and
you're talking about something that's
slower moving like debt how do you
capture something that's fast moving but
but you just but you can still timeless
and you can still predict out that's
going to be interesting so that's the
toughest area to deal with so with
something like that I mean you really
have to be looking at I guess you have
to be able to have I guess like
historical precedents for something like
that happening and like a comparison
that you're looking at this topic yeah I
can see that growing and growing and
growing it so cannabis is an interesting
one right so cannabis is interesting in
that like alcohol it had a period where
you weren't allowed to buy or sell any
right it which obviously that happened a
lot earlier for for in the alcohol
situation but it is analogous to the
cannabis situation and that it was black
market for a long time and then it also
emerged into a legal mart or its
emerging into a legal market and so
there is some precedent there and and
you can make that comparison back to to
booze and you know the the early 1900's
and and that kind of stuff so stuff like
that is interesting in that you know you
its immersion it's emerging it's new
it's going to be a big difference maker
in terms of it's going to have an impact
on the world but it's when you look at
it you have the feeling that it's not
gonna go anywhere it's gonna it's gonna
keep it's gonna it's not going to
disappear off the face of the earth like
I CEOs did it's going to keep going and
it's going to follow that historical
precedent in some shape or form where
it's going to you know as society
continues to become more accepting of it
as government's are pressured to be
forced to be more accepting of cannabis
use and things like that like it's hard
to see that momentum reversing direction
right what would have to happen for it
to reverse direction something crazy
would have to happen right so I think
something like that is it's a good
example of something that's not only you
know emerging but it's also something
that is unlikely to revert or disappear
I like how I'm one of your sweet spots
that you're listing for us here is the
ability to identify what is a prominent
emerging market that's catalyzing
serious business and technology change
around our world yet yeah like you said
is not easily going to be reverted and
how do you find then the most important
points around an emerging market like
cannabis to show and to inspire people
to get involved with awaken to and
involved with to try and get again the
fruits democratize to many people and
that does seem like a really important
way to to to be able to build the future
of visual capitalists so you gave we you
were giving us the example of books
that's a that's that's a really big one
the the the the how often are you
publishing one of these these really
strong syntheses and visualizations are
do you are you guys on all of your
subsections you have so many subsections
on visual capitalists are are they is
there like an equal distribution to a
post in all of those every you know at
leat every week or every couple of days
or and then how often are they being
blasted out in the mailing list and then
we'll also hit on the venture capital
capitalists Plus as well we'll talk
about that sure so right now we publish
one thing a day our goal is to publish
four things a day or five things a day
to build our way up to that we also want
to divide things upon a we're thinking a
North America and international spectrum
in terms of the content that we publish
as well and for now we published one
thing a day and we email it out once a
day and that is enough work for twenty
one people which is huge speaks to the
amount of effort that goes into
producing these things yes but it also
speaks to the effort that will be
involved in order for us to scale to
four or five things a day I don't think
that we can become a source of news or
media that is going to be hitting tens
of millions of people unless we're
hitting a wider variety of topics unless
we're hitting with there's more quantity
to both what's being public
and so and you also have to have those
big really crazy projects in there as
well that are just like you look at and
you're like how did they put this
together because this is so much
information so you know those really
like moonshot kind of projects and right
now it's hard for our team to have the
capability to do some of those but we
want to do things like that as we grow
in scale as well so yeah I mean it's
going to take a lot more effort and a
lot more
I think solidifying our processes and
just like what you stated at the
beginning which is like how do we
actually find things that are worthy of
being put in this format I think that's
probably the hardest question because
whenever we hire someone new on our
content side they think oh maybe this
will work or maybe this will work and a
lot of time they're their instincts
aren't necessarily and the writer like
they're close to the right place but
they're not necessarily in the right
place and so how do we find a way to
guide people to that and how do we and
part of our mission as well which I
don't think that we talked about but I
think is relevant is that we want to
take our ability to simplify complex
information and we want to teach the
rest of the world how to do that let's
talk about that yeah okay
so what we're doing in addition to you
know scaling out and building what we're
doing and the the vc+ which is are sort
of like premium extension beyond our
like normal stuff is we're also going to
be building something called it's
tentatively called visual catalyst
University which is way too grand and
way too fantastic for what it will
actually be so I mean maybe it will grow
into that eventually right but what we
really want to do is we assess we want
to build a foundation of knowledge so
that anyone can say okay I have all this
information but how do I turn it into
something that's compelling that gets
eyeballs that allows people to to
simplify this complex topic I think
that's something that can use be used by
companies organizations individuals
nonprofits everybody in today's
Information Age and in today's you know
Media climate where there's just so much
stuff so much content being churned out
every single day and there's so much
clutter there and so much information I
think that it's something that really
could help people figure out how to take
things to the next level in terms of
getting their story out getting their
information out and if we can leverage
that not we visual capitals but Society
if we can leverage these techniques
amongst a broader other types of
informational stuff that we don't cover
and get that out to people just as
efficiently I think that's going to be a
huge step forward in terms of helping
people understand more helping people
cut through that clutter of I mean when
I look at my Social Feeds every day it's
a disaster and I'm just like I don't
want any part of this yes luckily I have
geared my following the people that I
follow on places like tinted other
people that do great stuff similar to
what we're doing so I do find really
good stuff in there too but it's still
it's still such a tough environment and
I can only imagine if if for example you
live in a area where you don't you don't
know interesting people or you don't
know people that are talking about the
things that are happening in the world
you you haven't moved beyond that sort
of local scene of people around you and
for some people that maybe that's what
they like but other people might just
never have the opportunity to find out
what's happening in the rest of the
world which is what you know why I'm a
big fan of things like traveling and and
experiencing new things and you know all
the things that I'm sure that you're a
fan of but some people in their
information feed they aren't able to
venture out of their bubble either yes
and that's unfair to them that they
can't see things from other sources and
use use their judgment use their
problem-solving abilities to parse this
information and understand what's real
and what's not real and to and to learn
about the world from not just one
perspective so there's a real challenge
there and and coinciding with that
something that we did talk about briefly
before this conversation is there's all
kinds of media and news deserts out
there as well
locally in in North America all of the
local news sources have all been well
they've all been struggling because of
Facebook and Google taking their ad
money basically right so they've all
been consolidating it all been being
bought up by the same people and now
there's a lack of diversity a lack of
independent sources and then of course
that also happens on there the rest of
the the media side too right
all of business media or all of news
media all of these there's a lack of or
there are independent sources but
they're not prominent enough yet and we
need to get people out of their bubbles
and to see differing of opinions we need
to get them thinking critically about
what are what are your beliefs and how
do they compare to all these other
beliefs when you get people not worked
up about hearing beliefs from another
side of the spectrum because I think
that's the gut reaction for a lot of
people and a lot of smart people that I
know right now right they hear an idea
from a different side of the spectrum
and they are like oh my goodness like
how could anyone ever think that that's
the right thing to do right and I'm like
well you know there's a lot of people
and a lot of people have different
values and like you really have to
understand these different value systems
and things so it's it's an interesting
landscape but but our place and that is
you know our small place in that is
trying to do what we can with data to
help build at us so people do see those
different sides because data doesn't the
data doesn't lie right so to build out
some of those things so people can have
that foundation and and hopefully we can
start teaching other people how to do
that too I really love this last bit on
the visual capitalist University it's
probably going to make significant waves
with the overall
enlightenment and awareness shift around
our world and the transition from heavy
noise ridden
content that is falling into tribalism
and cognitive ease into more of the
visualizing and storytelling of data
that captures people's attention and
hearts towards harmony towards peace
towards prosperity for all I love that
aspect and it's great because it's the
tool and we've talked about this with
avoidant on the show and so many other
prominent scientists and people at the
edge of their fields is that it's
actually super important that when you
get to an edge of something like data
visualization and storytelling that if
you can take and compact a tool and then
share that with the world at large
absolutely then it makes it so that
everyone can then come on board use that
tool and start pushing the edge further
in all of their respective domains as
well
and I really like this a lot and it is
it's gonna be part of that tool is gonna
be the ability for people to share
[Music]
nuance and gray area but also in their
ability to story tell data that lands in
people's factual logical brains but also
in their hearts and emotions brings
those pieces together across all of the
different ways that you can actually
visualize it as well that visualizing of
the data and having these great like for
me it's something along the lines of how
can how can a an average person take
something like a unique piece of data
and then be able to almost in a sense
just have a bunch of maybe say I created
per mutational designs of how that data
could look and then pick which one they
think is going to land in the hearts and
minds of people around the world could
it be that easy that I
that I'm that I myself am am submitting
something like I mentioned on the show
earlier in our conversation just like
this idea of you know species amnesia
and only recently discovering a hundred
years ago this idea of a code of
hammurabi and how you know the
primordial constitutions and how
archaeologically we could find so many
more of those and so maybe this thing
that I want to share with people is
about how there's so much opportunity
for us archaeologically around the
planet to find these things and so where
are the next destinations that we need
to go where have the where as the
concentration and it seems like a big
concentration has been in this area of
like the Fertile Crescent and
Mesopotamia so you know maybe we do want
to double or triple down on our efforts
in those areas but then like the that
Amazon has another big you know or like
these areas of the the coastal like
cliff gobekli tepe and things like that
yeah yep yep very where I love that one
as well so yeah so that's just the
general idea then is um how can we
disseminate that an image that inspires
and in a in a post that inspires people
to want to awaken to the potential of
figuring out how our species even got
here and you know what you mentioned
earlier too about the median age of of
Africa being 18 when the imagination
creativity gets unleashed how can they
have a tool like visual capitalist
university to be able to disseminate
yeah and and I think I mean I think that
the area that we can cover is only so
small in the grand scheme of things
right on the Arkell it archeological
side of things on areas like that you
know I'm interested in those but we're
not experts in those fields so we need
people in those fields to take our skill
set the things that we've learned which
we want to teach people we need them to
take those skills and apply them to
their individual fields right so we want
I mean ideally you have people that are
at the best in all their respective
categories
taking
these communication skills that we're
going to be teaching and apply them to
their fields so that they reach more and
more people and you know we can we can
speak to the the business and investing
side of that but that's only such a
small side of the society right so you
know we obviously can't cover everything
we've dabbled in a bunch of different
areas but there's gonna be a lot of
people they're gonna be better at
teaching these things right and in
science right oh my god we touch on some
of the technologies that we think will
influence the future as far as where
we're growth will be and things like
that and but the the explaining things
like I mean going into the kinetic
engineering sure yeah or like going like
the subatomic level and all these kinds
of things where it's like I don't
understand how that stuff works I mean
like I I'm interested in it but I'm not
gonna be the one to explain it to
anybody so I think that that's all stuff
that we can people that if they have the
right skill set and if they learn what
we now know and we're trying to return
our best to to codify it and to make it
so it's a system rather than just you
know one or two people's intuitions
right and if we if we can do that
effectively then all these other groups
of people can take this and apply it so
imagine how much faster we could get to
the second quantum computing revolution
if quantum mechanics was able to be
disseminated in a way that leverage
correct visual capitalists University
skills correct I like I love stuff like
that thinking about that it's so
powerful how much faster can we push the
edge and advance society in these great
directions and also archaeologically
like figure out where we came from and
be able to show that to people more
effectively to inspire them to want to
double down on research in these areas
and stuff like that
okay so Jeff let's ask you about you
guys have a majority of the business is
sustained how how have you guys been
able to grow to a team of 21 yeah yeah
yeah so primarily were
an ad driven media company so like any
media company up well at least up until
recently most media companies are driven
by ads so whether you're the New York
Times or whether you're Forbes or
whatever like all these groups had a
large component of their revenue derived
from ads so on our end what we do is we
we have two types of ads we have native
advertisements and we also have an area
called the company spotlight and so
basically these are ways to showcase
companies that fit within the areas of
things that we're talking about right so
like for example if we're talking about
augmented reality as an investing
opportunity we're saying yeah this is
actually really interested in space our
salespeople will find an augmented
reality company that wants to profile
themselves on the site and so we'll have
a separate page for them it's you know
it's not something that is in the
editorial feed or anything like that
it's just a separate page we build them
a really nice graphic that explains what
they're about and we give them that
landing page so that people can learn
more about them if they want to and
that's a paid thing you know where we're
generating income from it and then
putting spa yeah and so and then we'll
also do is like through our daily email
blasts or something like that we will
throw in an ad to direct people to that
spotlight to learn more about that
company one more nuanced way that we we
also generate revenue is we will partner
with people that we consider to be
thought leaders so we've partnered with
Tony Robbins in the past it's great to
take his book so he did a book on
finance and investing yeah and so he his
team reached out to us and said you know
it'd be great if you took seven chapters
of our book and you visualize them
that's great and so what we did is we we
found the most compelling aspects of
each of these chapters we visualized
them we published them and of course
when we published them we're linking
back to the book so it kind of ends up
like the ideal situation there is it's a
win-win-win right for us it's good
engaging content it's read
new for them it's a way to showcase
their ideas in a meaningful way it's
coming from an authority someone that
people know who he is they respect him
and for our audience they're learning
something and getting a value out of it
as well and if they find that valuable
then they might find his book valuable
as well so you're connecting all these
dots in a really useful win-win-win way
and it's the same thing when we work
with someone like like McKenzie is a
good example of that too right they put
out they have all these PhDs that you
know people that are putting together
this massive amount of research but as I
say a 200 page document is only going to
be useful to so many a very small
spectrum of people right and so if we
can find a way to take that information
and parse it and find what's interesting
out of it and publish it and say hey
these are the key insights from this
report and you guys might be interested
to learn them if you want more you can
go here you know that's another way that
I think is a a win-win-win where
everybody gets value out of that right
so that would be another way that we do
it and then finally recently we've
launched something called VC plus and of
course VC University would be in this
category too of like something that
outside of the advertising realm that
people would we will have aspects of VC
University that would be free and then
of course we'd have Acts aspects of it
that would be paid where you can dive
deeper and deeper and deeper so that
would pay for us like making that
content but VC plus is basically a
subscription service that's a monthly
it's five dollars and 73 cents us a
month and it's basically for people that
want the level beyond what we currently
give out on the on the free side of
things so our main business will always
be that free ad driven model so that
everybody can get our information and
everybody can get our data but for VC
plus members we go sort of an extra step
of getting them involved so we will be
engaging them talking about them what
you want to see more of what do you what
do you want to learn more of we'll be
doing stuff like going behind the scenes
and showing them like how we actually
might work on a project so like later
this week we're going to be talking
about something that we first published
you know four or five years ago and this
evolved over time as we've published a
new version every couple of years we're
going to show them why and how it
evolved over time and what does
we made and and they're going to look at
that and they're gonna be able to get an
extra aspect of context there that other
people won't get but I think that I
think that will provide value to some
people and then we also round up our top
editorial pics each week of different
other visualizations outside of our site
that we think are really interesting or
compelling and so our editors each week
we'll each submit a list of things that
they found really compelling and you
know that because it's coming from our
team that if they're going to be you
know quality of data-driven
visualizations that are going to be
powerful and capture people's attention
so we put those all on a list and we
send them out every Sunday for vc+
subscribers I love the the ways of being
able to take what you're doing and and
and create models of sustaining and
growing what you're doing that are like
you said win win win models that are
models around the continued inspiration
and awakening of people to really
important knowledge I'm happy that you
guys have figured and we are shows to us
to figure out really good ways like that
as well
I wonder how many more opportunities
exist like that that we still have to
figure out where kind of like a bigger
dog can come in like a McKinsey or
Robbins and can say here you guys
interested in taking what we're doing
and compressing it visually yeah I like
stuff like that that's really
interesting I want to ask you some of
the questions that we asked on the
program that that are really tough
philosophically spiritually do you think
that we're all one you want to give okay
so that might be a common question asked
in these circles but maybe can you
elaborate on that a little bit so if
you're if you're Pro all one side what
what are most people thinking if you're
anti we're all one side what is the what
is the general thing because I can I can
throw
my answer in the context of that so are
we all one do we all come from the same
source
are we all interconnected is there
really no separation whether you want to
call it God or the universe of the
multiverse or whatever you want to use
as the words do we all come from one and
are we all one well I think we're all
interconnected but that's just a just a
fact of reality right because when you
look at complex systems and things like
that right you have to be connected
right because the air that I'm breathing
is literally the same air that you're
breathing the you know or the classic
example of a butterfly flapping its
wings in one place is going to determine
something somewhere else and there's all
of these inter currents happening all
the time between not only people but
everything else of every other object
right and that's just a that's just a
physical fact basically right because
everything that you do is going to
unless fits and even if it is done in
isolation is ultimately going to impact
someone else right because if you if you
stayed in your apartment all day and you
did not interact with the outside world
at all that's going to actually affect
your family and the friends that you had
made before that and that impact on them
is going to impact other people right
because they're going to be sad or
they're gonna be what so all the action
you take is going to be it as a fact is
interconnected with everybody else
when you look at it from a more base
level perspective of like are we all the
same are we do we all have that common I
guess I think we all have common
heritage all the same species all coming
from the same place
but today I think that there's a sense
that we you need to look out for
everyone
Allisyn you need to be you need to be
cognizant of other people what they're
going through I don't I don't know if I
would say that we're all literally one
conscience or some more one you know
group in that way though yeah like
feeling into your process of going back
and seeing that the lineage goes to
right one yeah so that I hunted percent
agree with right because we all stemmed
from the same root right so in that way
and in the way that I described in terms
of like physically being everyone is
interconnected in that way I think in
those ways I think it totally makes
sense that we're one I'm not so sure on
a on a more I guess conscious level of
like thoughts are all coming from the
same place or interacting with one
another I think there is your thoughts
are definitely changing me live that's
that's fair
but that is also the business that we're
in I think that there's a lot of people
who aren't in that in that that's not
their focus of life right so whether
they're aware of it or not though every
single moment of stimuli that we're
taking in is changing it's true and so
so that is that is the
interconnectedness that I do think
exists that has a lot to do with
consciousness that has a lot to do with
our physiology
sure after neurology yeah is then the
most upstream issue that we face our
feelings of separation and our lack of
feelings of interconnectedness I think
in modern society that this is a this is
a concerning trend that you know we are
more connected than ever but less
connected than ever at the
simultaneously right it's a paradox
right
you can send information to
almost anybody in the world in the blink
of an eye and you can you know we have
we have people on our we have people on
our site from North Korea like four
people every year I guess that's how
many people have internet sits there but
so you know you have this ability to
connect and interact with people all
over the globe which is pretty crazy but
at the same time I think there is a
pervasive sense of loneliness felt
throughout as well and so this is a big
paradox that you know we have to find a
way to to solve and I and I think that
tying to that paradox as well is a lot
of the I think a lot of the things that
you guys touch on and some of the things
we touched on here around information as
well because it's not only you're you're
at the same time you're connected to all
the information in the world yet
paradoxically people are in more bubbles
than they've ever been before so that's
the same thing right it's the same thing
as personal connection I have more
personal connection to anyone else in
the world but but you know people are
feeling lonelier but at the same time on
the information side of things you're
connected to more information like on
your phone you have all humanity's
information in one place that's crazy
yet people are in bubbles and seem to
know less about what's going on outside
of those bubbles than they ever have in
the past so that's a paradox as well and
so what did we do about those but I I
mean I know what we're doing about that
second paradox we're trying to get
information out in ways that I think can
help open up those bubbles a little bit
on the personal side on the
connectedness side I don't know I I mean
that's but I think those two things tie
in together yeah and then what do you
think is the point of this reality i I
think that there is I don't think there
is a point you don't think there's you
know things any purpose at all to this
being created no I don't think so I
think it's what you make of it
if you were making this reality
what could you see as the point of you
making it be
if I made the reality that is a really
great question I think that for me
I think it would be something along the
lines of making sure that everybody is
free in the most in the most like
expansive definition of that term
imaginable so not just free isn't like
political freedom or economic freedom or
something like that but free to do
anything that you choose in terms of
like being able to accomplish the things
that you want to do to chase after the
things that you're most interested in to
travel to where you want to go to
experience experiences that maybe you
couldn't before so that is something
that interests me I do not think that
that is the point of reality but I think
that that's my part of my personal
mission within this reality as far as I
see myself and so if I were creating
reality I would I would be hugely biased
in creating it as something that fits
upon that kind of spectrum of things I
love your focus on degrees of freedom
and just the word free I like that a lot
for self-actualization exactly and for
no one to tell you what you should self
actualize yeah you know you're free to
choose if you want to become the best
writer the best spiritual teacher the
best scientist whatever the thing is
that you want to actualize yourself in
doing you can do that I think that that
would be pretty cool for you to be fully
sovereign in your own advanced
sure of consciousness exactly yeah I
love it Jeff thanks so much for coming
onto the program and sharing with us
what you guys are doing I'm a huge fan
and I'm really grateful that you came on
thank you thanks Matt really appreciate
it thank you thank you thank you and
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
about all the great things that Jeff was
sharing with us let us know your
thoughts in the comments below check out
all the links in the bio below to visual
capitalists comm also their profiles on
Twitter Instagram and Facebook also just
profile on LinkedIn go and follow them
and go and share their content with your
friends and families have more
discussions online about the concepts
that they're teaching and make it a
common thing to try and yourself
compress really important data and share
that with the world
also check out the links in the bi below
to our show simulation help support us
and to continue doing cool things like
coming on site to great places like
Vancouver to have epic conversations
with people like jeff support us on
paypal patreon cryptocurrency can design
cool merch should get paid all those
links are in the bio below go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world we love you very much
thank you for tuning in we will see you
soon
that's a wrap
cool man as awesome I was really solid
thank you whoa that's great we went into
a lot of places
[Music]
you